[Musica]
il titolo del mio top e no antro posti
network e lo vedete scritto io sono nata
un paese che si chiama cameron che si
trova proprio nel cuore dell'africa
proprio al centro dell'africa il
cameroun bellissimo bellissimo paese che
tutti sono concordi nel chiamarlo
l'africa in miniatura perché nel cameron
potete scegliere in quale rilievo vivere
volete vivere in montagna la montagna
volete vivere nelle foreste equatoriali
se volete stare a sul mare c'è il mare
volete le pianure abbiamo di tutto il
camerano un paese ricchissimo abbiamo il
coltan tutti voi qui chiunque abbia uno
smartphone porta a quel pezzo
dell'africa con se abbiamo oro abbiamo
il diamante abbiamo lettere fertilissime
a non devo dimenticare nel camerun
siamo oltre 700 gruppi etnici però li
raggruppati diventano 300 che vuol dire
300 lingue locali non intera
comprensibile perché vi racconto questo
perché molto attinente alla at no anche
a un certo punto della mia vita
decido che voglio andarmene via perché
voglio andar via perché non accetto non
voglio fare come mi dicono i miei e cioè
sposare un uomo ricchissimo andare a s
la sua seconda moglie non ho nulla
contro quel modo di fare è il mio modo
di fare a casa mia si fa così non lo
critico però a me non sta bene
l'occasione mi è data attraverso
l'incontro con un francese
fuggiamo inseguiti dalla polizia
camerunese lui in seguito da interpol
arriviamo finalmente in francia dopo
aver traversato la foresta equatoriale
i deserti tutto il deserto del sahara
arriviamo infanzia ma in francia lui mi
lascerà non per che avreste voluto
lasciarmi ma perché il buon dio lo ha
chiamato a partire da quel momento io
devo correre io sono sola non ho nessuno
indietro io non posso fare non posso
fare perché sono andata via scappando
torna indietro sarebbe ammettere il mio
fallimento e la vita quella vita mi
porta in un luogo chiamato italia arrivò
in italia
anche qui mi trovo bene benissimo
nonostante tutte le sofferenze incontro
serie di persone che faranno sì che io
mi senta a casa l'italia
già l'italia come il camerun lo chiamano
i bear paese infatti anche il cameron in
africa lo chiamano il bel paese
in italia la vita mi porta in calabria
io non ho tempo devo cover di una cosa
io sono sicura che io voglio studiare
perché per me non studiare voglio
entrare in possesso degli strumenti
della conoscenza
io voglia di conoscere di studiare ma
non è facile
devo lavorare devo mandare i soldi a
casa dove mangiava anch'io dove per me
tra i miei fratelli e le mie sorelle che
sono rimasti di di studiare nel
frattempo hanno studiato e stanno bene
oggi la vita mi è difficile voglio
studiare mi ritrovo in un istituto a
cosenza tempo noce in cinque anni io
devo prepararmi per in cinque mesi devo
prepararmi per i cinque anni una
ragazzina e di cosenza in questa scuola
fa di tutto mi trova a tutti i libri
penso di essere stata l'unica perso la
fossa al mondo che ha studiato con tutti
i libri di tutti i cinque anni in cinque
mesi finalmente io ottengo il mio
diploma ma non mi basta
io ho sete o sete di conoscenza io
voglio conoscere incontro gente imparo
l'italiano
io voglio parlare questa bellissima
lingua la lingua di dante
voglio parlare voglio capire tutto io
leggo di tutto persino infornata vera
leggo tutto a un certo punto mi ritrovo
all'università io ho esattamente 30 anni
è il mezzo pensate a quanti anni sono
passati da quanto da quando all'età di
19 anni sono andata aver ci sono voluti
tutti quegli anni per poter raggiungere
quel luogo e se denis sui banchi i miei
compagni di studi hanno 10 11 anni meno
di me
quindi io sono o 12 anni di ritardo
rispetto a tutti gli altri ma non voglio
scoraggiarvi io chiedo aiuto
loro mi aiutano studiamo insieme andiamo
avanti di laurea 110 e lode
una festa non c'è nessuno della mia
famiglia però nel frattempo c'è la mia
famiglia cosentina quelli che mi hanno
accolto nelle loro case io voglio
ricordare a tutti quanti la famiglia
aiello il rettore dell'università della
calabria il centro women's studies
dell'università della calabria
i colleghi giornalisti sono laureata io
voglio fare la giornalista
non ho ancora in mente l'idea del etno
antonelli e pure stranamente nella mia
vita è esattamente quella etno anton da
qualche parte in qualche modo sto
realizzando di vento giornalista
all'esame finale per diventare dottore
di ricerca
i commissari mi chiedono allora collega
adesso che cosa vuole fare
io voglio diventare giornalista ma se
pazza giornalista con dottorato di
ricerca di ricerca
ma lo sa che enzo biagi non non è
laureato enzo bianchi o mio dio un nome
così lo prendo come destino come segno
del destino mi riprova a cosenza
io sono il professore a contratto
all'università della calabria
insegno introduzione l'antropologia
culturale nel contempo io divento
giornalista tutto il mondo
come parla tutto il mondo ne parla
perché io sono la prima donna dal mondo
della migrazione che riesce a
raggiungere questo questo livello
persino il giornale in giappone ne hanno
parlato in africa a tutti oggi tutti
proprio no la nel camerun
cameron one ha dato neanche notizia ma
non importa
nel frattempo io sono direttore di un
giornale la nostra redazione è proprio
un etno antonetti delle persone
soprattutto donne
io sono il direttore ma il caporedattore
anzi la caporedattrice è una donna molto
in gamba di lavoriamo su quel giornale
cambiamo abbiamo una etica forte
vogliamo fare del giornalismo con
linguaggio no con un linguaggio nuovo
vogliamo parlare alla gente vogliamo
scendere in mezzo alla gente
vogliamo essere la voce della gente ma
non centra un mucchio così
indifferenziato la gente ciascun singolo
e la città di cosenza lo sa la calabria
lo sa abbiamo lavorato tanto allo stesso
tempo all'università
io insegno ai miei ragazzi la bellezza
la bellezza della diversità con loro
parliamo di tutti i luoghi del mondo
nostro mondo compreso la nostra italia
compresa la calabria compresa
insegniamo quanto il diverso è bello e
mente però facevo il mio dottorato di
ricerca il mio progetto era etno
antropologo e immaginavo un luogo fisico
possibilmente anzi sicuramente dentro le
mura dell'università della calabria
dalle crode l'università della calabria
si chiama anche il ponte hanno
immaginato questo ponte che collegasse
tutti questi vari luoghi del mondo e la
mia mento e sempre durante il dottorato
è andata al 3 100 ai 300 gruppi etnici
del camion
ma il cameron come qualsiasi altro luogo
del mondo
allora io immaginato ma se in questo è
quanto dei scienziati di tutti gli
scienziati il fisico matematico
sociologo antropologo e filosofo tutte
le specializzazioni fossimo tutti quanti
in questo centro in questo luogo a
lavorare ciascuno ha il proprio
contributo sui problemi che attanagliano
il mondo ma il geologo come che tipo di
approccio avrebbe potuto avere di fronte
ad una nazione che sta andando a pezzi
per un problema specifico ma rispetto
quello specifico problema
il filosofo che cosa avrebbe detto il
sociologo cosa avrebbe detto ma è il
physique il fisico quale sarebbe stato
il suo pensiero il matematico avrebbe
avuto qualcosa da dire ciascuno in
questo luogo qui et lohan proposta
network a far cerca a raccontare a
prevenire io ho creduto e tuttora credo
che sia un progetto fattibile un
progetto bello nel frattempo non si è
compiuto il progetto l'etno anthropos
nei twork avevano la mia mente pura aver
avendolo sperimentato nel mio giornale
all'università con i miei ragazzi a
raccontare loro di quanto fossimo
fantastici nel camerun sentire tutte
queste lingue
tutte queste persone ciascuno col
proprio abito tradizionale come in
questo momento ne sto indossando uno
della etnia famiglie che da dove
provengo un abito millenarie con dei
colori e disegni molto significanti
significativi che hanno per fare con
questo blu che hanno a che fare col
mondo della spiritualità non l'avrei mai
immaginato che in quello stesso luogo
indossavo un abito poteva essere
a trent'anni di distanza che raccontava
questa storia ai miei giornalisti ai
miei studenti parlando
della bellezza della diversità dove
indossare un abito come quello che sarà
riconosciuto come appartenente alla
parte anglofona eh già perché il tar non
è suddiviso in due parti anzi prima
colonia tedesca
poi la risoluzione dell'onu che dice mai
più col colonia nel mondo e ci danno una
parte il protettorato francese io sono
dalla parte francese e dall'altra parte
il potuto protettorato inglese che
questo una loro abito rappresentativo ci
sono anche molte religioni
abbiamo tutte le religioni monoteiste
note la cristianesimo religione islamica
il buddismo abbiamo tutto ma abbiamo
anche le nostre religioni locali io sono
unanimi sta ma ne abbiamo moltissime di
regione oltre alle lingue porta tutte le
nostre diversità e a un certo punto
tutto questo paese è diventato come
altri luoghi del mondo altri paesi del
mondo è diventato un luogo ingovernabile
dove l'anglo fono se ne vuole stare per
fatti suoi e il francofono non vuole
sapere niente vuole stare anche lì per
farti suoi e non sono d'accordo si
ammazzano e si mette anche un costo
comincia micidio io che parlavo della
bellezza della diversità quella
diversità
ho pianto ho pianto e immaginando a
quella centro di ricerca che avevo tanto
sognato che si chiama etno antropologico
e la mia utopia ma una utopia non è mai
così pro portar di affinché si realizzi
che diventi realtà
continua ad esser speranzoso continuo a
pensare che quel progetto cielo è ancora
qui in tasca immagino che nella mia
città cosenza
nella mia regione calabria dei giovani
ricercatori possano prendere come
testimone
questa mia piccola idea ma perché
piccola grande nella misura in cui possa
contribuire a far sì che tutti abbiano
accesso alla conoscenza
credo nella educazione come arma molto
efficace per la lotta contro buona parte
che attanaglia la nostra umanità
grazie
[Applauso]